now the space race is back several
countries including the United States
China Russia India and Israel are trying
to reach the moon it's not just a quest
for National Glory scientists see the
moon as a Gateway a place to build bases
that could then launch missions to Mars
and Beyond
[Music]
one indispensable resource for manned
space flight
water
H2O can be used to make breathable air
for astronauts and fuel for Rockets
[Music]
the largest water deposits are in the
Deep icy craters at the Luna poles at
the moon's South Pole alone
researchers suspect there is as much
water as in Germany's largest lake
over the next few years an outpost is
set to be built in the lunar orbit the
so-called lunar Gateway NASA will build
it with Canada Europe and Japan
it wants to involve the private sector
more than before the new space station
will serve as a research platform and
later as a base for manned flights to
the Moon
its orbit should make it possible to see
The Far Side of the Moon and the South
Pole and to have constant radio contact
with Earth
nights on the Moon last for 14 Earth
days and the temperatures dropped to 160
degrees Celsius below zero that's a
major hurdle for long-term human
missions
but there are craters at the south pole
with rims that are almost always in
sunlight NASA wants to build a lunar
station at such a crater the so-called
Artemis base camp
initially astronauts will land in
transport craft which will also serve as
their accommodation during their short
stays as they explore the surrounding
Terrain in vehicles
[Music]
Mission the lunar base should become
more comfortable
spacecraft hoping the equipment and
robots will build the infrastructure up
to four astronauts will work here for up
to two months at a time
[Music]
The Outpost will also serve as a
springboard for a new mission
human voyages to Mars
well joining me in the studio is Joseph
ashbarger he is the director general of
the European Space Agency Esa and
Alexander Gerst he is a German astronaut
who spent a year on the International
Space Station where he was also a
mission Commander it's great to have you
with us here on DW news I'd like to
start with you Alexander why is it so
important to go back to the Moon after
50 years
yeah actually uh we don't see this going
back because we're doing something new
so for us it's a great step forward
we're going there not to plant a flag in
the ground or just collecting some rocks
but we want to be there as scientists to
stay to understand this well actually
it's an open history book about the the
first few billion years of Earth history
that we cannot read here anymore because
we don't have the Rocks anymore on Earth
they were destroyed by erosion they're
an open out in the open on the moon if
we study them we understand ourselves
better also the Moon is our next
neighbor we we compare it as a an eighth
continent that is right they are there
to be explored to be understood and it's
important for us because
if you think about it as humans we're an
island species we're live on this little
blue planet thinking that it's always
going to be there it's always going to
protect us but that's not the case the
dinosaurs have made that experience they
were hit by an asteroid the same could
happen to us their space weathers solar
storms out there that threaten our
society and we need to understand our
Cosmic surroundings so the Moon is the
first like look outside of our little
sphere and we we have the responsibility
to understand it to make sure that our
existence is insured so so you describe
the moon as being our neighbor
considering whether this might be a
success if we were to build a moon base
is there the possibility that we could
see people living on the moon at some
point
yeah I don't I don't see that you know
the Moon is is hostile and dry there's
no atmosphere there's
um there's you know nothing that that
would get you as a human to love being
there I I mean I've spent a year in
space and I always love to come back
that's a it's an important thing that we
learn but you could compare the moon to
Antarctica right a hundred years ago it
was not clear to people why should we go
there it's it's expensive it's risky and
it's full of ice but now 100 years later
in hindsight we understand that we were
right in going there and understanding
like Antarctica not by itself but
because it delivers data to us that is
important for our understanding of the
planet now there's lots of research
spaces even though nobody lives in
Antarctica just for fun and the same
will happen with the moon and why is uh
Mars such a Hot Topic when it comes to
the space race
so Mars can answer us two very very
important questions in my opinion the
most important ones is something that
every one of us you and I have asked
ourselves that are we alone in the
universe so if we go to Mars and if we
find traces of Life extinct or existing
it doesn't matter if that life
was was formed independent of life on
Earth that means just by like the first
view out the first
planet we look we find life that means
the universe is full with life right now
before we go to Mars and find out about
that we don't know we we're not we
cannot be sure is there life out there
or we alone in the universe
the second thing is Mars we see it
behind ourselves now is is a very dry
and hostile Planet but actually it used
to be
um it used to be
full with water had a thick atmosphere
it used to be able to support and
sustain life now it's dead and dry what
happened there and how can we prevent
the same happening with Earth all right
well stick around because we do
we do one of the European space agencies
key missions is to gather data about
climate change the information should
help scientists to predict natural
disasters such as hurricanes or droughts
The agency's Sentinel satellite system
flies over the same region every few
days acquiring information over time
well researchers can then see how land
sea and air are gradually changing
well let's turn now to Joseph ashbacher
who is the director general of the
European Space Agency the esa how could
this new satellite system change how we
tackle climate change I mean what we
have with the copernico system we have
just talked about the Sentinel missions
they are a unique set of different
satellites we have a number of them up
there and with all of them we are taking
the pulse of our planet literally that
we look at all the elements uh the
oceans the atmosphere the land surface
and how this Earth system works together
and we do need these observations to
really understand our planet to help
agriculture forestry ship holding
Farmers disaster management people so
really for their daily life and for the
job and the information they need but
also we really understand climate change
because we have these satellites
measuring it let me just say that
Copernicus is really quite a unique uh
piece of of satellites and information
we provide actually some colleagues sir
in the US for example colleague the gold
standard of Earth observation that means
Europe has created in the last 20 years
one of the best if not the best Earth
observation systems worldwide and even
NASA is participating in this program
and that's quite unique because normally
we are the small partner of a NASA
program in this case it is fair to say
that Europe has really established
itself as a as a major player as a
leader in observing our planet and of
course of course climate change
sustainability all these are key topics
which we address from space and yes this
program really helps us understanding
our own planet and just a little bit
more on that when it comes to trying to
understand where climate change is going
as a forecast what are you gauging from
this at the moment in terms of your
research I mean what we see and we've
just heard very recently that methane
emissions are increasing drastically
much higher than what we expected of
course we all know about CO2 as being
the main greenhouse gas that is creating
uh the warming of our planet of course
we aim at 1.5 degrees by the end of this
Century it is a very tough goal and we
can only reach it if we are taking
serious measures so one thing is of
course to get the measurements with
satellites and on ground systems and
air-based information but a much more
important task is to convert this into
information and what we're creating
there is I call it digital twin of our
planet so a digital twin which allows us
to model to simulate our planet and have
what if scenarios so what happens if I
change one parameter again against
another one for example in the energy
crisis now we are converting our all and
oil are supplies into electric energy or
more renewable energy sources and of
course you can simulate what that what
does it mean in order to be really
faster in beating your carbon targets
which we all have set up very
ambitiously so this simulation allows us
to really make sure first of all that we
understand the system but also make the
right decisions in order to do the right
steps the right measures to get there in
terms of reducing the carbon footprint
therefore minimize the impact of climate
change I imagine a lot of very
interesting equipment will be used for
this Mission could you talk us through
some of it oh yes there is a lot of it I
mean we have satellites that measure
that the radar sensors on board radar
can look through the clouds and measure
day and night so that means anytime uh
whatever the daytime whatever the
weather is you can take pictures down
here on our planet and that's quite
amazing that's of course very useful but
also we have sensors that allow us to
measure sea level height with millimeter
accuracy so you can imagine the
satellite flies in 800 kilometers height
and measures with one millimeter
accuracy what is the average sea level
height on our surface with red
altimeters which are on the satellite so
some of them are groundbreaking
technology and science which we're
applying and yes this is quite a unique
system and it's actually quite cool very
cool very interesting as well
um Alexandra I'd like to end this with
you you spent a year in space clearly
got to see things that many of us
haven't had the opportunity to do what's
your perception of how we are dealing
with Earth right now
well it's always you know
hard to look down on Earth onto Earth
from space and seeing things that we do
down there we see war from the outside
we see how people treat the planet at
the same time we see how fragile it is
and even more importantly we see how
alone we are you know when we grow up
but down here on Earth it looks infinite
but if you see it from the outside on
the backdrop of a black hostile Cosmos
where there's nothing there it's just
from a few our of our neighbor neighbor
rocks and planets but apart from that
there's nothing there if you see that
and put it in perspective
it usually fills us it did certainly
with me and my colleagues usually say
the same it fills us with a concern that
we're not treating our planet in the way
we should to be sustainable to make sure
it's doing biosphere it's doing what
it's doing for us even in the future and
that's something that's a message that
we want to bring out it's one of the
most important things that we bring back
as human humans to fly to space is the
perspective but at the same time we're
trying to make things better and to you
know to give scientists the data at hand
that they need to understand this
problem
well thank you very much indeed for
taking the time to speak to DW news this
is uh Joseph ashbacher director of the
European Space Agency Esa and Alexander
Gutt the German astronaut thank you so
much for your time thanks for having us
thank you very much